these don't even make sense dude
all right uh where's Katrina
what the [ __ ] was that
oh in the back hey how are you Katrina
who are you here with
your husband nice and where was your
honeymoon
she's really flexing on these two
we want a cruise to another country no
hurricane like adults
where'd you guys get married
[Music]
okay what the [ __ ] is going on around
here you guys not allowed to have
weddings here what's happening big
wedding destination yeah and did you
guys serve booze at the wedding
what were the choices of entrees if you
don't mind me asking do you have anyone
[Laughter]
oh that's real trashy
oh I [ __ ] love it
you take all the bacon bits you want big
fella
loaded mashed potato bar and he's gonna
be talking about that for three hours
yeah we're gonna be driving away any
mashed potato bars around here I want
that at my funeral
it's in three months if anybody's
available
none of that broccoli and cheese [ __ ]
either sorry I'm contractually obligated
to make that joke okay
it's in the bylaws
how much did you guys make for your
wedding
what'd he say
he yelled out he knows exactly what the
[ __ ] it was
okay okay
Katrina this is about your dad
his dad this I I I need a little I don't
understand it are you garbage oh so you
said it about your father-in-law I
apologize are you garbage if your father
father-in-law uses AC window unit to
stay cool to smoke ciggies on the back
porch foreign
so he's got the air conditioner going on
outside
that guy's all right
shout out to your old man that Global
warming's all propaganda
Al Gore can suck my dick
I like my heaters hot and my air cold
I assume there's no enclosure right it's
just blowing out in the backyard
screens yeah that's great dude
screens are there shut up I don't want
no bugs on me
I did dude that's [ __ ] awesome that's
next level gangster [ __ ] yeah it gets
hot down here in the summer right
yeah [ __ ] it
what'd you say
that one more time
it's just not even just on the ground or
something
it's on the ground
that doesn't even do anything
he just kicks it on
[Applause]
is there like rattling and moving all
around and [ __ ] like that
that's for sure plugged into a orange
extension cord yeah
into the neighbor's house
[Laughter]
he's got a remote
hey he's a gentleman
he's not he's not some dirt bag smoking
cigs outside in the air conditioning
oh that's [ __ ] fantastic clap it out
for Katrina and her father-in-law
man